Let's look at how the camera model and
the perspective of the camera model is extracted from this.
We can actually simplify this a little bit.
What I can do is now take the focal length which was on this side and actually
just start saying is, okay, let's mirror it on the front side of this too.
Which basically means is now I can move the sensor here, and
if I move the sensor here I can put the x i and y i values on this side.
And one interesting aspect of this simplification is now I
can see the image to be also upright as the object is.
Of course you notice that if this object was farther away,
the image would be smaller.
If the object was closer, the image would be larger.
And that's exactly what we notice when we were looking at,
of course, lenses and how the impact of lenses with moving objects was.
Again, this is a idealized version.
Pinhole is this point here.
We would be replacing this with a lens.
We looked at these equations before this is how we would compute the values of
both x and y put in each and every object the location of
the pixel that would be related to of course where this point is on the scene.